[Music]
[Music]
today we're going to be talking about
pins alright and we're going to approach
the subject through a collection of
little assortment of puzzles on some
some you know so easy just that they
just kind of illustrate the concept of a
pin and some will be a little more
challenging and we're also in between
the puzzles we're gonna look at a game
played in the early 20th century between
Akiba Rubinstein and my C's Jacques my
C's that being said let's get started
and put the first position on the board
on I'll let you guys look at this this
good should be the answer should be
jumping out to some some of the more
regular tournament players and we're
gonna be you know in line with the
general scope of the show which is to
introduce tactical themes to the 600
1200 USEF
rated player and to help help said
player develop the ability to identify
and recognize these themes at the
various stages which they occur
throughout our chess games in that
spirit the tactical team today is pins
and the sister theme so to speak will be
a discovered attack chosen because it's
somewhat similar to a pin optically but
not necessarily mechanically or the way
in which it works but this is an example
an illustrative example of forced matin
1 anyone want to shout out the answer
what's going on here is we Black has two
pieces pinned the Queen and the knight
are both pinned the Queen pinned by the
bishop on at 3 and the rook is pinning
the knight and for that reason we can
play a really pretty look and move like
Queen a6 and deliver matin 1 it's
against the rules or it's illegal to
recapture with either one of the black
pieces so pretty clear forceful
illustration of a pin let's go on okay
whose move is it right again another
really easy one just to kind of
illustrate and show the properties of
pins um feel free to shout out any of
the shout out the answers if you guys
see them or raise your hand that's fine
yep in the back limb the Queen on b7 of
g7 rather um with the bishop move we
unmask the attack of the rook h1 on the
King delivering not mate but delivering
a deadly check which will allow you to
win the Queen after all right about here
this one's a little more subtle not a
one mover I'll wait to move one thing we
do is identify the pin piece how are we
gonna exploit that weakness
or identify the piece that can be
potentially pinned right creating the
pin leaving black and zoogs along is it
essentially you can pick any legal move
for black and whites next move is almost
always going to be b6 okay this is a
thematic way to exploit the pin theme um
you attack you know attacking the pinned
piece in general but attacking it with a
pawn is something that you will see in a
lot of your games and for games that you
look over okay mate so that's actually a
really good question what happens if we
play Knight c5 threatening attacking the
rook with the night what we do is follow
through with plan a play b6 and if black
carelessly gets greedy and takes we do
over check me which okay another
somewhat easy one white to move
how are we going to use this idea of the
pin King e5 winning the Knights very
good he only has one it only has one one
option in several legal moves but all of
them results in the same same sad way
you lose the night because it's pinned
by the bishop this is white to move here
there's another easiest one we're
getting closer to the game just to point
out some features of the the position
White has kind of a dream position here
right he's got the Black Knight on c7
pinned by two of his pieces
how can you exploit that pin and in it
if any of you guys remember the Opera
game it's not exactly the same style of
mate but it's reminiscent of it on a
roll
on fire on fire okay the knight
obviously is unable to recapture because
of hook the tin from the seat for the
rook okay
this one's cool and it throws a lot of
my students so it's white to move what's
the best continuation here hot beautiful
okay can't I capture on passant if you
play that you guys not knowing no no
well but yeah being sneaky aren't I um
why can't he keep capture on Tucson in
this way be cooked very good yep because
the pawn is pinned and that one's kind
of you know somewhat counterintuitive
we might yeah we might not always
consider that but whenever the opponent
King is exposed in such a way and you
know a lot of his flight squares are
controlled by our own pieces we want to
look for a super aggressive moves like
that
okay pans and counter pins white to move
and right now black is already in one
pin right the rook on rook on f6 is
pinned by the rook h6 to the king how
can we create another one winning that
rook beautiful
the idea being that now the rook cannot
recapture on h6 because it's a second
pin has been created of the brook to the
King to the Queen rather so not good
because we lose the Queen right here
there's a small catch small caveat in
here this one set up with black to move
blacks you know only reasonable move but
now my question is what do you guys play
with white here you have the rook pin to
the king
do we just win the exchange or do we
calculate a little bit deeper in and
think about the the consequences of what
happened what happens if we if we take
immediately on e5 yeah yeah you attack
with the pawn right exactly
yeah lost it yeah this way yeah winning
the rook keeping the extra piece and the
nice centralized passed pawn which you
you know imagine Lee can escort to a
promotion with the King and Bishop with
a little difficulty okay and now the
discovered attack main three you guys 30
seconds to work this one through white
to move yeah
the discovered attack being one in which
a piece has moved on masking an
unmasking an attack from the covered
piece the previously covered piece would
like to move you said Bishop b6 yeah
that's an excellent choice check what's
you follow up after that out where and
where do you well King let's say let's
let's do a blindfold and just say the
moves out loud just for me just for uh
because this one's only a mate in three
um well he can go to e7 and if he goes
to c8 or c7 there's a force matin one
right
with Queen on the dot on da but if it
goes to e7 it's a little more stubborn
how are we gonna follow up so Bishop b4
check good first move correct
King e7
because we're two moves away from me and
especially when we have a puzzle where
it's been where we know it's of course
may we can it you know I just started
looking at not in this case but silly
moves even sometimes in this case that's
not required but forcing moves like
checks should be at the top of our list
of moves we're calculating and now I
should be pretty clear to everybody
right that there's no way that you're
getting out of mate you can give up the
Queen that's the only resistance and
it's not really much resistance at that
but
but it's interesting yeah to to take
that into consideration um that there
are the forcing moves even if it at
first we don't see a positive outcome
for us I'm there worth looking at and
spending a little more energy doing our
best to really calculate precisely
because you can get cool forest mates
than the late middle game sometimes okay
on to the game okay between Akiba
Rubinstein and Jacques my C's both
players from the early 2020s century
Rubinstein especially was one of the
strongest players of his day and we're
gonna see these games that we're looking
at are definitely gonna be closer to our
ideas of what normal chest looks like a
as opposed to the morphe games which
looked like you know a strong player
playing e4 and just crushing amateurs
I'm here black puts up a little bit of a
resistant a little bit more resistance
um and we have you know a deeper opening
something a little more tame than than
the previous games that we've looked at
so the first pin of the game Bishop g5 a
pretty common idea and these qgd lines
not so popular nowadays but it still
playable I
one of the main ideas here besides
creating the pin against the Queen is
that we want our bishop outside of the
pawn chain so that we can play e3 now
and not have a bishop a bad bishop
confined to the dark squares on our
first and second ranks one move or two
okay so before c66 is again a playable
move not the most popular way for people
to proceed in this kind of position on
Bishop e4 I think might make a little
more sense you know just developing your
stuff getting ready to Castle kingside i
but one could argue that black has some
subtle ideas here um namely he wants to
create a pin of his own but he has to do
a little prep beforehand um he wants to
pin the knight c3 to the king but not
with the bishop with his queen and so in
order to do that he needs he has two
problems he needs to solve one he needs
to create a path for her to get to the
check-in square and two he needs to deal
with this pesky attack tonight or this
pesky Bishop attacking the knight on f6
if the Queen moves immediately then you
know Bishop takes f6 is an option worth
considering guys destroying the blacks
King side pawn structure making some
ugly double deaf pawns um so keeping
those ideas in mind we look at these
next moves and we see the Queen a5 idea
played here doing a few things one
breaking the pin so now the knight is no
longer pinned and if white for whatever
reason decides to give up the bishop
pair playing Bishop takes f6 then Knight
takes f6 looks perfectly safe for for
black and for that reason Queen a5
creates the threat of Knight e4 for
black attacking the pinned piece twice
which is what we want to do once you've
pinned a piece you want to just keep
attacking it
generally speaking okay so Rubenstein
gets the general idea of all this sees
that 94 as a threat in other positions
you know in a movie still played today
we were looking at this on the database
on it's got really good results for
white I think 57%
he plays Knight f3 2 D 2 9 2 D 2 over
protecting that e4 square
black continues to attack the now not so
pinned piece when uh one other purpose
to the 92 move is that it also
interposes and breaks the pin important
to note that so he creates a little more
pressure on that Knight c3 and we see a
logical move taking one more step
towards completing development but also
on defending for a second time the twice
attacked nice e3 and we see black put
his idea into motion white responds with
his planned defense and with the simple
recapture black
black use of the discovered attack theme
I noteworthy because you know some
people might you know at least notice
that the e4 pawn is is on under attack
here and loose but totally irrelevant
because there's a piece of greater value
under attack which needs to be saved so
Bishop h4 is played giving black time to
take another step towards finishing
development getting his King to safety
castling kingside white follow suit
getting ready to developing his final
miner getting ready to also Castle
kingside
and here this is you know class just aim
towards getting everybody used to you
know basic tactical ideas and then will
work a little bit on calculation but you
know we can't look at games without at
least thinking a little bit about the
middle game plans and and what's going
on and trying to understand uh what each
side is thinking and so that being said
here we can say that white wants to
castle right it's black to move but just
looking at either side and evaluating
the position because we're in the middle
of the game um we can say that White's
plan is you know Castle kingside finish
development and continue to make the
most of the space advantage on the Queen
side whereas Black has some more serious
problems he has some development issues
he has a horrible Bishop which has no
legal moves no squares available to it
because it's blocked on the night by the
ninety seven so he aims to liberate on
as we were looking at this with Ange and
earlier you know the engine is just
screaming to play e5 here to create some
some some lines open lines for your
pieces up with the idea of Knight f6 and
IDI and and you know put the
LightSquared Bishop somewhere and even
Knight f6 is probably worth considering
here
and it's safe to assume that black is
thinking along the same lines but he is
afraid of playing a5 and losing this
eforp on on in some line so instead so
he chooses instead to protect that e4
pawn with the idea of playing a 5 later
sometimes in the immediate future the
computer doesn't like this plan and
wants to play Knight f6 here and and
just develop your stuff but he didn't
have engines back then so he played it 5
and now white makes a simple decision
one that you always almost always have
to make when one of your nights on you
on your third or sixth rank if you're if
you're black if you have black pieces uh
is pinned by Bishop sometimes you need
to put the question to the bishop which
is what white does here forcing black to
make a decision whether or not he wants
to lose a tempo or the bishop pair
question back there
oh no okay um he decides to give up the
bishop here and here he probably would
have been okay to just trade Queens he
wants to hold on to his strongest
attacking piece and dreams of you know
getting it over to the Kings side to
help that pawn mass and maybe get some
attacks going morphe makes a move that
you know may excuse me uh Rubinstein
makes a move on that you know the engine
doesn't recommend doesn't hate closes
the position I'm pretty sure the main
idea is he's creating those uh he's
creating space on those squares on the
light squares c4 so he can check the
check the King and one way or another
with the bishop or the Queen so the so
he played the c5 move
this was another kind of funny move but
but not a completely losing for black
but uh you know sensibly he's was
reacting to the threat of Bishop e7 here
and white makes the decision to
recapture with the rook over the idea of
just owning the D file for the remainder
of the game
so this is taking the taking an
advantage of the queenside space vintage
that we were talking about probably
played with the idea of repositioning
the Queen falls victim to the obvious
tempo gaining move Bishop g3
Queen gay escapes the attack and we
seize control of the D file solidify
control of the D file and here you know
why doesn't crushing but he has a
significant advantage goes for the check
with the idea of creating this battery
autumn's with Bishop c4 perhaps
considering attacking the knight I mean
the the Brooke on the 8th with a move
like Bishop f7 um black prevents that
with 96 he recaptures here and this was
interesting on we were looking at this
and asking ourselves that what move
looks natural to you guys here how would
you recapture with black to move I know
my inclination at least was to look at
that the bishop takes lines um which
don't necessarily work you guys are
interested we can go over it but it's
kind of outside the scope of this
lecture um so he chooses to take with
the Queen instead giving Rubenstein the
opportunity to create the penultimate
the second to the last pin in the game
how can we create an absolute pin an
absolute pin being one where a piece is
pinned to the king well says okay
and here black certainly starts to go
astray
I think if I remember the eval right
White's up significantly nutnut nothing
too dire but pretty bad about 1.5 if I
remember but black makes him move I
believe here Brooke g8 is playable but
he sees that his back rank is weak he
plays h6 creates a little loose or air a
little flight square for the king and
white creates the final pin of the game
which may not seem significant but
something that we should always do one
of the most important features in any
chess position is you know which pieces
are pinned and and so on period which
Pete you know which if any pieces are
pinned
I'm always something that we need to be
looking for Queen c3 not necessarily
being the strongest move it in the
position I think the if I remember right
the engine one the Queen v4 or something
like this but it it's cool and
definitely good for this lecture because
it illustrates the whole pin idea and
here is the big losing move how can we
win with light here wide to win and move
with a killer tactical idea now the pin
is a minor theme this tactical idea is
is actually a deflection or you call the
traction may be beautiful okay
and now that pin on g7 comes into play
we would like to play g5 blocking that
pesky Bishop attack right can't do it
though because the Queen pins the pawn
and here my C's resigned okay I have a
few more puzzles these ones will be a
little bit a little bit more difficult
than the first set so I'll just like to
move and we'll find the winning
continuation pin is a theme here and I
will throw out some hints these are like
I said are a little bit more difficult
I'll throw out some hints after twenty
seconds or so maybe maybe a little
longer if you guys want and I picked a
lot of these just in case you or any
players close to you in strength showed
up and this one's not necessarily super
hard but requires some calculation
definitely okay so a few different
important features to note in this
position um we have an advanced past
pawn on f7 currently unprotected but you
know imaginably could be protected and
we we could just discover a protection
you know by moving that night to some
square but we also have a super weak
back rank right we don't have any black
pieces really defending the back rank so
much yeah it's under under defended at
the very least so we can play a crazy
move in line with a theme a lot with a
lot of the previous puzzles giving up
our strongest piece I for a guaranteed
favorable attack Queen takes d6 forcing
the c7 pawn to recapture on exploiting
its the weakness of its pin to to the
weak back rank meaning it was pinned by
the rook c2 to the weak back rank and if
we go with the direct line you can get
some stuff like this going
after after this check we have some
serious mating threads going on
for example Queen takes g6 and me
alright
we're made to matin made made on EI
after rocky let's do this one because
this is a good example of forcing moves
and this is more of a back rank a weak
back rank is more of a theme here than
the pin but there definitely is a pin in
this position the f7 pawn is pinned by
the Queen Queen on d5 and under attack
twice so how should we proceed with
white here and there's a force twin in
here in a small amount of move so I'll
tell you guys what what it is if you
want but makes it more fun sometimes if
we just approach it like it's a game
that we're actually playing and we don't
have someone telling us that there's a
force to win in a set amount of moves
but the big gain is forcing moves and
when we're calculating these lines in
our head usually they flow pretty easy
because our opponents don't have a lot
of responses so what are some ways we
can play forcing line Queen takes pawn
check rook takes rook takes pawn rook e8
check rook f8 know it takes rook right
rook takes rook on King takes rook and
then we have that classic rook and
Bishop mating pattern right so this
one's not put in so Queen takes rook
takes
again the back rank is under defended
got a pretty little mate okay well thank
you everybody for coming out and
participating yep glad you enjoyed it
hit like share subscribe thank you
[Music]